[Musik]
ich will zu dir nach hause
ich habe angst dass ich alles verlieren
werde
[Musik]
ich habe wie immer gesagt die frau die
ich meiner mutter vorstelle die werde
ich heiraten
ich erzähle ja immer witze und ich
erwarte eine reaktion
aber da kommt nur ein ja das war lustig
[Musik]
juni
lerby trocknet noch ein boss und auch
nicht grade andere plänen kaffeetisch im
leben wenn er die nationale liga besser
funktionieren muss radikal i entscheiden
oder für gezeigt dass in spanien
gefahren und die schweizerin simona
italien gewonnen allerdings
ich saß im monat in einem nachtclub also
simona die straße an und lud sie zu
einem drink und
da sind wir
[Gelächter]
ich rief werd simona und doch in der
altstadt von modena
ferrari gesteht grund warum die beiden
smart italien gelandet sind doch wann
ist maschineningenieur schafe die die
entwicklung von formel 1 motoren
war es schon immer dein traum für
ferrari zu arbeiten
ja das ist so
einmal dort zu arbeiten schien mir
eigentlich ein ding der unmöglichkeit
ist weltberühmt
denn jetzt groß
die jede und handeln und denken
ja
und wenn aber warum herrscht seit ich
auch alles zurück und es gab also dass
ferrari modell glaube zuschlag gaben
letzte punkt ist der qualität wenn du
nicht
ökonomie und sowieso zwischen erstellte
doch nicht nur über den sieg
also ich mache das aber derlei wo die
onyx gemacht dass wenn du mich
keiner gelernt hat sich die beide 2010
paris
die alten spruch groß gemacht und er
happy rhöner als ingenieur geschafft gut
41 fernbeziehung führt paris und trug
aber dann sind italien und ferrari ist
spiel unter punkt wo sie analysen
entscheide
[Musik]
das wird das video machen
die schicken
[Musik]
ich musste mich auf die bestmögliche art
verkaufen ich dachte auf
schweizerdeutsch zu fragen sei eine gute
idee
es hat geklappt sie hat ja gesagt
[Musik]
angefangen hat alles
wieder vorbei
erzählt fabian aus dem glarnerland auf
dating
abgeleitet was es da so fuhrmann
zum treffen
[Musik]
oben
und findet
so herzig
leiter
lang ich mochte ihr blondes haar und
ihren
[Musik]
der humor
das tue ich habe eintraf konnte ich gar
nicht richtig schwimmen
wir gingen schnauzer
ich hatte angst schwimmen zu gehen um
nicht unterzugehen kaufte ich mir ein
keyboard er sagte nämlich dass er angst
hat
ich wollte hier natürlich die zeigen
dass ich angst hatte
[Musik]
das periphere roman cm könnte werde ich
mit fabian schnell klar sie
[Musik]
ganz im gegenteil zum francis trotz der
schöne zeit hat er noch gemeinsame
zukunft sehe
[Musik]
als ich sie zum flughafen brachte sagte
ich ihr sie solle mich nicht mehr
anrufen sie aber meinte dass sie
wiederkommen würde
das unsere liebe eine chance hätte
als sie dann in der schweiz vor
versuchte ich nicht an sich zu denken es
ging so weit dass sie sich nicht mehr an
rief ich wollte nicht wieder
liebeskummer wegen einer fernbeziehung
haben
aber dann kam sie zurück und all die
gefühle kamen wieder hoch ich bin froh
dass sie zurück ist
alles oder nichts für fabienne und
francis kaiser und der beiden ein voll
auf risiko gesetzt
manu hat fabian anklam-land und ihrem
job als sachbearbeiterin artwork seit
und ihrem herz gefolgt
[Musik]
mit die beide immer krieg wie vierte von
honolulu gerade mal zwei minuten vom
legendären strand weg
am francis ihn älter sind philippinos
wurde 80 staaten liegt andritz intercell
bericht sei geboren
so wer kann schneller und besser lumpi
us rollen nein das ist kein wettbewerb
für mich ist es das erste mal dass ich
mit einer partnerin zusammenlebt ich
habe nie mit einer freundin zusammen
dies perfekt
[Musik]
irgendwas muss ihre frauen wg vor der
familie kaiserin klammer land umgegangen
sie die jüngere schwester von fabian das
powermanagement und einem nach alten
koffer packt und ist auf amerika
ausgewandert auf san francisco und aus
wenn ich mich im hsk die ganze zeit und
dann sind wir schnell vorbeigegangen
bei einer 20
[Musik]
eigentlich hat laut novelle reise und
die schufa roadtrip westküste von
us-autor abgeschlossen hat iris lemmer
dramatische wende immer uns gewöhnlichen
irish pub in san francisco darin ist der
messe und es ist liebe auf den ersten
blick
[Musik]
anders die schwester fabienne hat sich
neue zietlow mit zyklen eine
fernbeziehung
letztes mal habe ich drei wale gesehen
ich habe hier noch nie einen ball
gesehen
die waren da draußen
drei von m2 große und ein baby
unser herz und er wird immer das ist ein
gurt er ich will ich nicht so
offen und zeigt seine gefühle nicht so
extrem wenig gott aber ich weiß wie man
einmal im herz habe ich ständig für
immer den gar
nicht gewiss sei dass ich das muss
lernen wie ein besserer mensch gemacht
natürlich es gibt immer probleme im
leben aber
die liebe hilft bei allem da man alles
teilen
[Musik]
noel und trend schon viele klippen
umschiffen zum grünen seien sie was sie
noch nicht wissen ein großer test statt
die nach kurz bevor
[Musik]
es ist jetzt nicht so dass ich voll auf
das taxi war und ich bin auch rechts
kritisch gesichter denkt ja sich ja doch
ganz andere kulturen ich bin noch nicht
so lange in afrika will ich denn das sei
wirklich und da bin ich allerdings im
gegensatz zu
[Musik]
ihre kultur sind komplett
unterschiedlich aber das ziel ist gleich
mehrere hamm und chris wend ihr
urteil gefällt es dir ich liebe es
mailand ist einfach nur flach
hier ist das glas immer grün
und das ist nicht staubig das ist ein
großer unterschied
bei dijon für gemeinnützige organisation
sambia jetzt in den ferien der schweiz
wohne zweite miriam ihre ältere im
thurgau
ich hab dir wenig größte gegeben weil du
keinen käse magst
das schmeckt gut ja sogar sehr gut
beim ersten treffen was du sehr nervös
nicht war krieg
ja ich war sehr nervös geradezu
ängstlich
lieber wenn die beide vorbehalt sambia
trotzdem soll der krise und bezug zur
schweiz überholt
ich mag ist dass es hier so ruhig ist
das ebenfalls ist für mich einfach nur
wichtig ja für zukunft dar wer weiß
nicht ob mir für immer werde den sender
blieb oder nicht
das ist unser haus von hinten mit den
solarpanels
so viele solarpanels auch hier ist es
einfach schön es gefällt ihr
alles zu planen das ist typisch sie
monate ich erinnere mich nicht exakt an
dieser situation
aber ich kann es mir gut vorstellen das
ist genauso wahr
[Musik]
bitte spanische schwiegereltern vfl
hätte trick funktioniert sie einst im
monat ist herz geschlossen
und jetzt sind simona und hornbrille von
der l und im iran
[Musik]
die freien
ein spanische vater und der schweiz und
italien
[Musik]
das herzige erstellt immer um nach der
mitte doch
genau das war
das nicht sowieso
mehr abfangen und französisch
für eine sprache
mit tischte das schwierige und eine
chemie sanglichkeit will mich eigentlich
drücke ich mit mir und ehrlich zeit
französisch ich hoffe und setze ich rede
aber das ist nicht die sprache nicht
ganz natürlich aus
wechselt man die sprache wird man zu
einem anderen menschen so viel sprache
vielleicht manages to run a brawe chance
beim ras lanuf wachse
spanien hat sich beim run alles um autos
und egal wo sein herz irrt sie die
sammlung aus büro modellauto und
erinnerungsstück muss mit
[Musik]
hersteller formel-1-motoren omid
entwickelt jetzt für ferrari in einer
vitrine im autoalltag
hier habe ich meine vielen souvenirs
bilder und unterschriften von fahrern
das ist der 2010 red bull zu dieser zeit
hat renault den motor für red bull
entwickelt und wir haben mit diesem
modell die weltmeisterschaft gewonnen
[Musik]
das ist der motor und unser team ich
habe schöne erinnerungen an diese zeit
und
das ganz persönliche krisen vitrine
eines tages kam simone sagt er sie hat
er ein geschenk für mich
sie gab mir diesen kleinen ferrari
california
das ist eine der kleinsten ferraris die
es gibt und sie gab auch dieses armband
ein kleiner ferrari ist auf dem weg
die schaut dass sie an und fragte bist
du schwanger sie sagte ja
sie verstand meine sprache sie machte
mich sehr glücklich
[Musik]
doch man hat bei ferrari sind betonte
und simone
eigentlich ist sie ergotherapeutin aber
zieht daher ihren kurs schwierig
schweizer diplom wird nicht richtig
anerkannt
darum hat sie im land von der mode jetzt
ihre eigene linie lake gründet sich
nicht weiter für sind
new york city und mich
beruflich
so identifizieren
familie
gelebt hat hat
eine klassische rollenverteilung hat
simona im alltag immer wieder zu
[Musik]
du bist wege im duo das alles zu klar
dass auch das ungleichgewicht gibt es
momente der bezirk oder auch ein
schwieriger so dass
das ungleichgewicht mit so er das land
sachsen und davon und das nichts mit
wenn ihm die kette der
berufsvertretung daraus zurückziehen
weil mir geht's die kompromiss
machen
für simona ist klar irgendwann will sie
zog die schweiz
[Musik]
ich wusste das dorf ein roadtrip passt
ich wusste aber nicht dass du am anderen
ende der welt lebst
ich dachte vielleicht lebst du in los
angeles das ist nicht so weit weg da
kann man hinfahren aber als du sagtest
das sei die schweiz da dachte ich
[Musik]
san francisco schweiz über 9000
kilometer distanz einmal über den
atlantik und quert und usa
[Musik]
das sieht sehr empört dass ein beide
schnell küste
besonderes ist der neue clark sie hals
über kopf alles trocken gott gar nicht
[Musik]
mit einer 20 sie gott fertig sie mit der
ausbildung und der stelle
berufserfahrung sammeln konsequenz trio
und die beiden feiern bce klebt
[Musik]
nachdem wir sind im meetings schlauen
geschlichen das ding wächst
genau
neue hätte der schweiz durch bildung als
kindergärtnerin gemacht
ich hab einfach am max eyth wenn ich
hunger da komme ich zum auf meinem blog
schaffen will für das bin ich gegangen
ich werde das mit ihm machen und ich
will auf meine eigene visum da sieht
dass ich nicht abhängig von der bin will
ich finde das nicht so einen druck weg
bezirk und mini short san francisco das
ist die einzige wo anerkannt ich zum
auch einer wiese musik also eigentlich
das mini einzige chance gesehen habe
mich beworben und zum glück hat es dann
klappt ja
hallo anna
aber sehr schön
allerdings ist auch hier die wurden
jetzt beste freunde männliche und ruby
ruby wie geht es dir denn heute sie
unterrichtet in der deutschsprachigen
schulen jetzt lernten short darum für
die hughes geht es dir tatütata
[Musik]
machen quatsch
jetzt flughafen kopf coco komme
hierher
der strenge staat der als kalifornien
machte 27-jährige
schwertsik schwenkt sie und dass man
humor antreffe
duell vom ist schweiz
ich bin halt sehr sehr an mitteln
ich max mannesmann ist linke nicht bei
mir haben und dann werde ich echt
depressiv
sie bloggen immer wieder in ihre heimat
zum geschenk
ja
[Musik]
wieso
spricht schnell und ohne land
[Musik]
bei
lancia mit hawaii bilder wir server und
tourismus francis nyt am hut er schaffte
am ort wo hawaii immer ganz anderen
zusammenhang welt wie die bekanntheit
breitet der französisch monteur auf der
militärbasis von paul habe
gleich nach der highschool ging ich zu
haben ich hatte keine klaren beruflichen
vorstellungen
die armee ist ein guter start
und vor allem bieten sie stipendien fürs
college und
man bekommt lebenserfahrung und lernt
verschiedene länder kennen
reise und länder entdecken das hat für
der freundeskreise in re aktie
als ich militär war wurde ich 2009 2010
nach afghanistan geschickt
es war eine sehr beängstigende zeitung
ich wusste nicht ob ich überleben würde
aber es machte mich auch zu einem
besseren menschen
ich wurde stärker und begann mich zu
glauben
und auch darauf zu vertrauen dass es
einen nächsten tag geben wird
[Musik]
in perm aber habe ich eine stabile an
bord ich kann für mich und
familienaufgaben
und später auch für eine familie
[Musik]
jungwirth welt entdecken ist für fabian
fiel um belastet
fußball ja als dabei entsprach
aufenthalt gemacht doch normal auf
dienstag fähre hat sich francis
kennengelernt
[Musik]
honolulu oder sprachschule worauf sie zu
achten
dank der schneller vor ort mit dem
francis hat fabian noch gut 8 minute
eine arbeitsbewilligung über hope of
green kreuth aber als unbeschränkte
offen teils recht hat sie über zwei
jahre gewartet und hätte wie er im film
matrix beamte müsse vorstellig werden
ich bin der vogel wir bieten keine
gewähr irgendwelche kollegen frage mich
das nicht allein an der frage
schließlich fielen dann aber doch glaubt
dass sie weckte liebi die usa will
bliebe
[Musik]
also
macht muss doch und so ist es doch
es geht auch noch ein anderer weg machen
nachdem das album noch nicht so
sicher nicht nur mich jetzt ebenso
geachtet oder auch so machen für die
tournee ist richtig lag und es geht ja
um seine
schulter erwischt wo man vielleicht
vorher nicht hart wenn man immer im land
und ich im garten klappte
[Musik]
der erste griff oder abruzzen mit zwei
weg ist castello von montevideo ideales
ziel für den familienausflug
was mich beeindruckt hat es in monaco an
die jury offenheit sie machen kein bogen
um die schwierige themen von rabbi
nationaler beziehung und das buch
wahrscheinlich wenn unsere erste
verliebtheit als level werbe wofür bei
die post
welche job möglichkeiten gäbe es für
dich in der schweiz
die schweiz hat zwar keine klassische
autoindustrie aber die schweiz hat eine
große maschinenindustrie
dort gibt es möglichkeiten die
pens aber er würde nur in die schweiz
ziehen wenn du dort einen job hat ist
[Musik]
der kompromiss ist dass wir in die
schweizer nicht an einen neuen ort gehen
aber wir gehen nur in die schweiz wenn
sich eine gute möglichkeit offen
august
[Musik]
eine berufliche zukunft des
freistaates obwohl jetzt ich kann mir
sehr gut vorstellen noch mal periode da
in italien bringt ihn noch nie ich finde
es ist wichtig dass man wenn mir vor der
schule liegt das ist wirklich bewusst
weil wenn man jetzt das ist wirklich
aufschlagen es sieht versteht und und im
moment quasi muti da es
bleibt spannend
[Musik]
mehr
die kerle
[Musik]
wenn ihr die emotionen zeigt aber wird
einmal drogen bestimmt war
immer ehrlich und
gibt mir die sicherheit von eigentlich
ist
es ist immer der bahn
trotz lerby unglück neue form ist ihre
familie und die vertraute umgebung
[Musik]
ihre familie schon immer gesehen
es war das erste mal dass noel ihrer
familie in der schweiz so lange nicht
sehen konnte
das hat ihr sehr zugesetzt ich sagte ihr
wenn deine schule einwilligt von der
schweiz aus zu arbeiten dann buch ein
ticket und flieg heim
und genau das hat neue gemacht
ihre familie das neue im glauben an dich
sie hat nur frühen den vor ihrer moore
dreh klein
und dir hätten all ihres ahnungslose
mami wird zum kaffee glaube
[Musik]
[Applaus]
da
[Musik]
das gab bei die töchter innerhalb vom
halbe ausgewandert sind ist die zusam
kreis und sie
dort verloren fügte im haus ich
natürlich intensiv
mit gehabt haben
für den
kunden dass sie
drogen und und vor allem versuchen
aber von montag an das leben
miriam ist die erste frau die ich meiner
mutter vorgestellt habe
in unserer kultur ist es nicht üblich
dass man irgendeine frau nach hause
bringt für mich war es immer klar die
frau die ich meiner mutter vorstelle
werde ich heiraten
[Musik]
noch drei monate schweiz zog die eins
der ärmsten ländern der welt
miriam und chris sind wieder die
eiskappe sambia ihre mutter von chris
sind süd zum titelblatt
[Musik]
der christen sinti mutter hatte eine
beziehung
stellt die stiefel sind sind vater ist
gestorben oder chris 12x ich
[Musik]
habe ja etwas mitgebracht
es ist für esther und taboo
kleider für die hochzeit
talkshow inas bartek denkt so das passt
ja ja es muss einfach
zum mittag gibt es ein seltener luxus
es ist sehr groß ich habe es heute
morgen gekauft wirst du es für uns
schlachten
das musst du für uns
ich habe schon einige geschlachtet jetzt
bist du dran
fast 3 frankreichs prachtexemplar kostet
viel geld sambia für die im durchschnitt
über 100 franken im monat
kannst du mir helfen ja ich komme
einfach und detail vom schlachter wird
ist ja eigentlich meistens nicht vor
zeigt und auf uns zu bereiten und den
innereien sind so die hinterhalt die
wissen genau wie ihr was mache ich
einfach lief und ich also ich habe
einfach noch nicht gemacht darum finde
ich sagen wir noch schwierig zu muss
genauso machen wie sie
yoga ist das vom kochen oder braten
nicht
miriam tief eine entscheidung wir werden
das braten
ok jetzt
[Musik]
wo ich alt werde übernehmen sie meine
stellungnahme
in einer kultur ist jetzt meine mutter
sie ist mami sie ist jetzt meine mutter
ihrer familie sambia ihnen die rote
heißt es von der gesellschaft akzeptiert
hielt während ihre eltern unterstützen
andersrum
mama martha und weiter er witwenrente
noch späteren altersrenten über und das
obwohl familie november zum mittelstand
ich dachte nie dass ich je eine weiße
frau heiraten würde ich sah diese
möglichkeit nicht
wo würde ich eine weiße frau
kennenlernen und dann ist es einfach
passiert
ich bin so froh sie ist einfach
bezaubernd
[Musik]
derby stufenplan für die miriam
gestanden wo sich sambia groep
schweizerin eigentlich doch nur welch
schaffen
jetzt wohne tigris und sie sieht ruhr
zum thema in luanda viertel war es
bessere wohngegend von kabul gilt aber
als nicht mehr vorhanden
fest drücken und treiben
mein vater hat mir das waschen
beigebracht
wir sind sehr genau wenn es ums waschen
geht
eine waschmaschine kriegt das nicht so
gut hin
unser immer schön lecker und alle jetzt
haben wir auch sehr wert auf das ihm
alles klicken und die spielzeit
unbedingt drei niveau immer alles so
perfekt glättet habe aber der größte
name leider muss jetzt zurück und danach
geklebte
menschen in sambia händen starke familie
sind ohne dem armen land ruhm über liebe
familie
vater mutter und kind meistens
irgendwie ist es die luft wo man sich
dem antrag findet dass man nicht einfach
nur immer sie nie eine familie hat
sondern dass eigentlich die ganze
familie ja ein teil ist und ihm auch
komisch
sich oft so dass sich familie sehr krass
unterstützt und aber wenig bedeutung
jeder so dass man dann gemeinsam
eigentlich der person denn hilft und
dennis oft halt einfach so jammert er
mir der kriegsfolgen will sich avisiert
da ich mir sicherlich schwierig zu
handhaben
wurde chris mit will wie sein vater von
eur ist familie warum lügt standen
als ältester amy chua abbrechen und
geschaffen
sport da hat sie die familie zwei
mitleid und immer nur billig zum film
und fotografie möglichkeit ich habe die
batterien über nacht geladen
und jahrespraktikum die ursachen machen
miriam der schweiz wirtschaft studiert
noch einmal humanitären einsatz in
afrika
wie geht es dir
[Musik]
bist du zufrieden mit dem laden mary ja
danke ich bin zufrieden
mit mama maria geschäftsfrau wurde
miriam tiere zu mikrokredit verholfen
mit fünf dollar startkapital hat sie ein
laden aufgemacht sie braucht
gemütlichkeit und paraffin die ganz
familie und neun enkel prinz tore
die organisation für die miriam möchte
die andere animieren seines geschäfts
tour
die beide die erfolgreiche geschichte
oder mama mary für website dokumentieren
mama mary bitte stell dich uns vor
[Musik]
b
zu den neuen überraschende wenn die
knochen
aber was ist denn eigentlich körpers
also dass das visum abgelehnt hat und
dann bin ich natürlich gott also völlig
entsetzt
die bewegungs verlängerung ist acht
ländern oder einfach so und grund ist
die trauben und jamie t shirts was ihm
ist wieso mischt
das
problem sie untermalt sind nicht groß
wie das viele andere macht für sichere
aufenthaltsbewilligung
[Musik]
ich werde gerade ein bisschen traurig
ich möchte zu dir nach hause kommen
agnes merkt wenn ich meine
er spürt dass du traurig bist
[Musik]
ja
ich habe angst dass ich alles verliere
nein du kannst uns liefern
[Musik]
wenn neue wieder zurückkommt of san
francisco ich völlig unklar
[Musik]
er hat sehr schnell löst dass wir das
mit sammer küren sie schicken wir gar
nicht zur diskussion standen am anfang
doch reichlich mit mir keiner will was
ist überhaupt eine minute lang sie und
ich habe genau gewusst wenn ich kann
dann
ist natürlich alles alles anders alles
anders
[Musik]
ap
b
für 20 jahre und corinne und derweil
schon miteinander leben und viel applaus
bei anderen moment erlebt
ich briefe zürcherin und der ägypter
aber küste vom roten meer in scharm el
scheich
das ist nicht alles das hätte ich gerne
aber wir haben viele gute erinnerungen
an dieses boot die kinder tobten auf den
segel drum wir verbrachten viel zeit auf
sie
sie hätten fünf stern hotel erleiden die
stehlik er hätte das notfallmediziner
geschaffen ich wusste nur dass es im
hotel jemanden mit blonden schönem haar
und langen beinen man nannte sie long
legs
langbein eines tages wurde chorin sehr
krank und braucht einen arzt ich zu
diesem zeitpunkt aber in kairo war
musste man ihr einen anderen aus und
habe mich dann sofort kontaktiert
den lauf genau so also lernen es ist
immer gut wenn mir schweizers kühlen
müssen die aussage ist schon recht wenn
es lohnt sich wahnsinnig
[Musik]
das geheimnis einer erfolgreichen ehe
ist nichts ist selbstverständlich und
denke bevor du redest
[Gelächter]
respekt natürlich denken bevor man redet
ist auch ein zeichen des respekts
nehmen dich selbst nicht so wichtig
nimmt das leben leicht wir sind hier auf
der welt nur auf besuch und habe zwei
badezimmer und zwei badezimmer seines
und ihres an alle jungen paare wenn ihr
es euch leisten könnte schaut dass ihr
zwei badezimmer habt
die beiden pc ex deep sky schließlich
schon forsch das vierte jahrhundert
erfahrung als bei aber wenn fängt
eigentlich genau ist geschichte igor in
und um weil lohnt sich noch ganz genau
[Musik]
da haben wir uns zum ersten mal geküsst
ja da haben wir uns zum ersten mal
geküsst
bevor wir christen sagte ich sie sagte
ich bin nicht der typ der einfach um
spielt das ist ernst für mich ich sagte
ich habe verstanden auch ich meine es
ernst und dann kästen wir uns
lag russisches verspreche sie so schnell
hoch zieht mündete einzig die ägyptische
bürokratie er deren elan kurzfristig
gestoppt
[Musik]
es war ein langer bürokratischer prozess
schlussendlich hatten wir 57 stempel und
das heißt 57 stempel von 57
verschiedenen leuten und das formular
war so lange
kann ebenso
unglaublich obwohl sie nicht einmal nur
gesichert während euro hoch
du hast ihn untersucht natürlich spielte
ich bei diesem spiel mit wie stand auf
stellte sich hinter ihn
ich zeig dir meine entspannungsübungen
dann öffnet er das große buch wieder und
sagte glückwunsch sie sind jetzt
verheiratet
[Musik]
so hey
als glückliches paar zeitlich nicht hin
sein sohn und der tochter und es lebe
immer ferienort und ein
perfekter rahmen sich glücklich huhn
vorstellen
[Musik]
aber irgendwann macht sich technologie
alltag breit und zwar überall und jeder
familie welt ist in sharm el-sheikh
ferien aber der notarzt weil hat vor
allem krampf die krume die hexen
einmal wollte ich meinen jungen vom
kindergarten abholen aber er weigerte
sich mit mitzukommen und weinte das war
der weckruf ich war ein fremder für ihn
mein gott sagte ich mir was mache ich da
überhaupt
immer dieses kommen und gehen
ich fragte mich will ich das auch in
zukunft haben nein
ich wollte unbedingt mehr zeit mit
meiner frau und meiner familie
verbringen
es gibt viele frauen die wohl sagen
würden deswegen habe ich dich nicht
geheiratet
das verstehen und darum sage ich auch
corinne ist unglaublich bei ihr kommt
alles zusammen belastbarkeit stärke und
gleichzeitig ist sie sanft und
liebenswürdig und
mut zum risiko
sofort york seit wurde weil ein neuer
fonds vorgeschlagen hat als zweitstudium
zum chiropraktiker usa die beide hände
alles trug wo sie sich zum hofgarten und
sind mit ihrer familie und beruf
schicker
[Musik]
unsere beiden kultur und sind
unterschiedlich
ich würde nicht sagen dass sie
zueinander passen
aber die unterschiede erweitern unseren
horizont
[Musik]
mit ev bn und im franzis in hawaii sitz
lepper auf der erste blick im rössli
noch ferien muss
[Musik]
der monteur mit der philippinischen
wurzeln und sachbearbeiter aus dem
glarnerland genieße die ihren freien tag
[Musik]
im alltag gibt es bei punkt was
möglichem einig sind aber der
unterschied bringen findet
ich habe aufgehört konserven zu kaufen
mit essen aus der dose bin ich
aufgewachsen weil es günstig aber und
einfach zuzubereiten
fabian hat mich überzeugt dass das
ungesund ist
das ist eine der sachen die ich in
meinem leben für sie geändert habe
aber spam es sich immer noch
dosenfleisch ist grässlich
mit sport
pünktlich
es hat keine eile etwas zu erledigen
wenn man an den strand geht muss man
nicht zu einer bestimmten zeit dort sein
der strand wird immer da sein
so verschieden sie aussieht die beiden
schnell gemerkt großzügig sie und
kompromiss sieger das buch zum können
glücklich werde mit genannt
aggressiv
sieht acht woche sitzt neue schulden
schweiz fest und jetzt geht's endlich
post vor der amerikanischen botschaft
dass ich sogar
dass sie zum stressig und zieht dann hat
sich einfach so
durch die
heirat zu die der sorge hatte den film
zu die
wohnzimmer zu bleiben will einfach ne du
bist einfach fremd kontrolliert oder
gestört und durch kein fluss kauf mit
und der zuschauer einfach gottes gott
wird mega freue
[Musik]
ich kann es immer noch nicht glauben
dass sie kommt
ich weiß was sie nicht mag sie mag keine
rosafarbenen blumen ich glaube ich nehme
rosen danke einen schönen tag noch
[Musik]
die ferien morgen aber phx brangelina
das
ist die einzige zeit am tag könnte ich
was machen kann ich brauche den sport um
arbeiten zu können sonst verliere ich
energie
derweil ist 450 und wird mittlerweile
als sportmediziner zweimal mit seiner
frau corinne betrieb der eine eigene
praxis in kairo
[Musik]
jetzt cool das ist für die stadt und das
macht und 1 12 toren aber also ich dass
nicht durch drei
und haben ihren traum mit der typ dann
geht es um einen kauf
[Gelächter]
ich dachte für eine kleine pfeife wäre
zeit
ich brauche sie nach dem training
sie hasst es
ist sechs uhr früh
[Musik]
sind für die ausbildung in der schweiz
foto ap es ist kein
filmstar jude 6
sie wohnen im süden von kairo in einer
gated community anderer bewachten
siedlung von deiner geht's wieder zwei
millionen stadt
[Musik]
es sind nur ein paar kilo mehl du bist
du der praxis aber die beide in dem mit
dem taxi
am anfang von mir selbst doch es wurde
zunehmend zum kauf
momentan ist noch kein verkehr aber in
einer stunde wird es wirklich hart
wir wollen entspannt in der praxis
ankommen
[Musik]
der hauptstadt
vier jahre sexy derweil hat in chicago
es studium zum chiropraktiker gemacht
[Musik]
trawler praxis sind klar verteilt gorin
ist für die organisation zuständig
derweil kümmert sich um patienten
trägt die einlagen sieht gut aus
konzept verteidigt und darauf eine
öffnungszeit dafür ägypter alles andere
als normal sind
dieses ziel oder wie sie vision ist
wirklich am morgen früh anfangen und
dora ziehen und den
seitengassen davon kann man schon früher
wurden und bin angefangen haben wir um
halb
sieben
als chiropraktiker behandelte weil
patienten mit problemen bewegungsapparat
und
der erste mit der spezialisierung sie
mit patienten aus dem ganzen arabischen
raum
[Musik]
wird endlich gut
ich bin ein wenig aufgeregt aber
wenn ich endlich dort bin ist alles gut
[Musik]
lang lang höchstens sechs mal wieder
sind und jetzt kommt alles plötzlich
schnell
[Musik]
also ist es die heiße samba für den
moment und mir logitech sowie mann ist
wohl fühlt aber mir dort weg sagt dass
man sich einmal an aber die schweiz wenn
die familienplanung und so im raum steht
ist es auch für mich einfach wichtiger
dass kassenarten sprechen schweizer auch
schon billig und so
sambia liegt im südlichen teil afrikas
landesschau mehr als 11 tiefer der
manager muss mit weniger als zwei dollar
am tag
vom kanton thurgau
größeren die kontraste sind für miriam
ist das alltag aber was wie sie viel zu
oft wenn sie die straßen von kabul
unterwegs ist
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
meistens der krise damit weiß man
manchmal 100 prozent wohl fühlen weil
man einfach so schnell
weil man halt einfach
unfallträchtiger gemacht
ja und dann ist für mich immer einfacher
wenn ich einfach volle kasse bieten aber
mittelbar spricht und nicht eigentlich
geräte das ist ein schönes leistung war
das gottmadinger und dass dann die ich
verstehe miriam jetzt viel besser weil
ich das selber in der schweiz erlebt
habe
auch wenn mich die leute nicht
angesprochen haben spürte ich dass sie
viele fragen
nicht nur tut habe ich im alltag immer
wieder das thema sondern aus geld als
fielen rund fotograf für die ente chris
klug für das leben in sambia schweizer
coop miriam einfach normales ganz andere
finanzielle verhältnisse
in der schweiz lernt man schon von klein
auf wie man geld sparen kann hier ist
das anders
wegen der schlechten wirtschaftlichen
lage leben die menschen von der hand
ich wuchs damit auf die dinge zu
schätzen die ich habe
sicher hat miriam mehr geld als ich
aber das spielt für mich keine rolle als
mann bin ich in der lage dafür zu sorgen
dass es immer genug zu essen gibt und es
sie auch sonst nichts fehlen wird
sondern halten
bevor ich ihn überhaupt
nicht irgendwie komisch so oder so für
mich
und ja es ist
normal und okay damit eigentlich
mit viel gelassenheit und zuversicht
könnt die beide ihre gemeinsame zukunft
entgegen in der sparte vans führung
[Musik]
ich dachte nicht wirklich an
konsequenzen
ich hatte nur augen für chor ihnen und
ihren charakter
passen wir zusammen
wird es eine erfolgsgeschichte sein
und jede herausforderung zeigte umso
mehr
ja wir sind füreinander geschaffen
[Musik]
dass crysis 2 wird diese core i3 immer
logisch derweil kennengelernt
[Musik]
kairo ist die größte stadt des
afrikanischen kontinents die schwarz
ziehen ihren lud und chaotisch
[Musik]
noch immer lange da die arztpraxis and
green und derweil vier ob ich sie für
ihre marine bahr mit blick aufs wort
sein vorgibt
über 4.500 jahre sind seit ihrem etat
von gizeh sie gehören zu der älteste
bauwerk vor der menschheit
interessanterweise glauben viele die
pyramiden wären in der wüste
dabei sind sie mittlerweile direkt am
stadtrand
warum seid ihr überhaupt nach kairo
gezogen
ich glaube dass der nabel der welt am
mittelmeer liegt
die kinder sollten die wahlen haben
stell dir vor sie wohnten in kairo haben
in den staaten geliebt und sie kennen
auch die schweiz
es geht darum eine umfassende
persönlichkeit zu formen
ehrlich gesagt war es auch ein
finanzieller aspekt
[Musik]
aber
wenn es passiert
drei wochen nachdem nico sind ist
arabisch früher liegt eine
stromproduktion com heute möglich wäre
richtig gut das gibt es ein bürger
reagiert das neue regierung das ist im
moment also kommen also der vor allem
metern acht damen jannik schlafe nicht
mehr will du hast du gesponsert und
während so einer brücke und in sindh
sind diese unfälle und dass das hat
wahnsinnig und wir sind immer gleich sie
ich kann das auch
wenn ich hunger vechta ak ich kann meine
tasche nachdem becker mit laptop
und
und wegrennen und bis in grenzen
das war ein seltsames gefühl
ich fragte mich wozu ich bereit bin um
einer familie zu verteidigen
bist du gewählt jemanden zu verletzten
oder sogar noch weiter zu dienen
ich merkte ich hätte kein problem
jemanden zu verletzen der meiner familie
etwas antun will
direkt danach verschob sich die macht zu
den muslimbrüdern
sie waren natürlich nicht qualifiziert
sein land zu führen
wir wussten das wird nicht lange gut
gehen
nichts ist nachhaltig die stromausfälle
der mangel an wasser und elektrizität
doch die dinge änderten sich dramatisch
und sehr schnell
der preis dafür war hoch
nun haben wir eine militärregierung aber
zumindest konnten wir im land bleiben
[Musik]
ich sage ich nie als typischen
amerikaner du erscheinst mir eher
europäisch
wie du denkst
du bist weltoffen
schweizer sind beim ersten treffen eher
verschlossen sie öffnen sich erst nach
und nach so bist du überhaupt nicht du
bist von vornherein offen
diesbezüglich bin ich amerikanisch ja
das ist seltsam total gemischt
[Musik]
da geht's nicht nur tv landschaft hat
ihren eigenen reiz besonders für europa
wo ist der schweiz rund wird neu
[Musik]
o
neue und damit so jung sie sind so viel
1 schutz seiner tore gemacht vor sieben
jahre hens im pub in san francisco sehr
schnell miteinander abstoßen
ferien auf der erste blick ist fern bce
wurde mit hoch und tief bis neue
schließlich ein job als kindergärtnerin
gesundheit und der grüne eu usa ziehen
und wie geht's
momentan stimme die bezirke dass ich
eigentlich nur noch der nächste schritt
war sprich dass er die große frage
stellt
aber wir wissen dass er sehr über
leitern an sich
[Musik]
hier ortet für rufen tags bewilligung 1
bei die website sondern erst wenn
riswick sicht sind die suisseid lang
wird's nimmer touren
[Musik]
in der millionenmetropole kairo ist der
verkehr im alltag ist uhr thema auf wii
trinkerin
challenge doch mit der oper vorne von
links vor rechts muss schon sehr
konzentriert sie ob er es ist spannend
es gibt die shows regler hydra halten
sich die wenigsten
fahrer wird wo es platz- und erkalten
doppelt projekt gegen sagte der
zweifache mal aufs burgblick autopapiere
der hoffnung dass leverkusen muss
corinna die unterwegs im vorort von
kairo wo felix baitz wohnt
mit ihrem arabisch können sie sich im
alter akteure schlau aber für das
richtige sprach lang is not sagt kohring
mit ihrem marvel rät sie nun in englisch
war wahnsinnig gern besten europäische
rechnen ich finde es schwierig
und so viele tretet andere sprache dann
ist für mich einfach dazu aber ja also
dass ich glaube dass sich eigene familie
gelöscht
und ich daran dass ich gebraucht
bevor man in ägypten heiraten kann muss
man den wert seiner frau angeben und
danach bemisst sich die gebühr die man
zahlen muss als
wird muss man mindestens 25 kerstan
geben also ungefähr 25 rappen
[Gelächter]
die investition lohnt 220 jahres in der
ungarin verortet und sie ein zwei
erwachsene
[Musik]
nein schön euch zu sehen
denn hunger und chloe sind für ihre
hotelfach es bilder westschweiz
aber was wenn ihr jetzt ist der
beschriebene was sind sie fußball
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ich hätte sie so gerne hier
[Gelächter]
der wechsel des pcs englische aber
arabisch zu mich
geredet ihre raten
wir wissen zumindest wie man auf dem
markt früchte kauft
[Gelächter]
englisch ist die familiensprache
und das liegt an mir
das problem ist sie sprechen andere
sprachen die ich nicht verstehe sie
haben ihre geheimsprache
am anfang dachte ich es wäre großartig
wenn sie auch arabisch lernen würden
stell dir vor sie sprechen englisch
französisch schweizerdeutsch hochdeutsch
etwas spanisch und dann auch noch
arabisch aber es erschien mir ein
riesiger aufwand für die kinder und auch
für mich ich fast den ganzen tag weg
wenn ich dann mal da war wollte ich
nicht auch noch das zuhause in eine
schule verwandeln sie waren ja schon
tagsüber auf der internationalen schule
und mussten dort mit verschiedenen
sprachen da kommen sie wechseln die
sprache je nach gesprächspartner
das ist fantastisch
keystone vielmehr als sand und beton im
südosten von kairo wird es neues
wohnquartier aus dem boden stampfen da
entsteht als künftig die high von
corinne und dem wein
das mit dem weißen rahmen
der kaufvertrag für ihre boni kennt die
beiden vorjahre unterschrieben
der rohbau fertig und dann mit dem
innenausbau
[Musik]
als schmiede in ägypten
habe christian imfeld werden im winter
ja ja und versichterte so mehr zur
iss mini
und das ist gut und das ist alles total
auf und was ich auch völlig scott die
tische mit der hand liegt dazu in cochem
ist
wirklich so dass ich hier wohne ich
lappen und
aus der villa mit garten und pool piepst
innstadt wunsch
ist das ist der nächste schritt auf
eurer reise aus paar eure kinder sind
nun aus dem haus wie ist das für euch
das ist ein neuanfang für uns beide
bringen alles vom alter hus der ordner
oder wie machen wir das und mehr wissen
die
ferien oder das ist nur um die
gewalttat machen sie so wenig aufwand
und die so lang wie ausbessern zum
schlafen ist es auch eine schmerzhaft
also das los los los leichter regen wir
was sind die herausforderungen in diesem
neuen lebensabschnitt
es wird gut werden auch gar nicht viel
anders als jetzt
wir ziehen hierher in unser neues
kleines paradies
wir werden hier seien auf reisen gehen
die kinder sehen und an zurückkommen und
weiterarbeiten
ich finde das ziemlich befriedigend
[Musik]
und weil kennengelernt
für lucas neill verabschiede mich von
denen beide
[Musik]
wenn ich euch in fünf oder zehn jahren
wieder treffen wo wir bis sein
vielleicht in las vegas man weiß nicht
warum nicht auf jeden fall in einer
neuen wohnung
bei einem neuen projekt zu einer neuen
idee wichtig ist dass wir zusammen sind
[Musik]
in der bezirks- oder vor ort und die
nato nicht
einfach oder man muss sich ungewöhnlich
an ihm selber entscheidungen treffen und
dann sind auch noch so entscheiden wo
denn nicht einfach einfach hofe werde
und will die andere person ganz andere
ich stelle einfach vom hintergrund von
der kultur
die kulturellen unterschiede und
herausforderungen werden immer da sein
es lohnt sich aber einen schritt
weiterzugehen und voneinander zu lernen
ich weiß nicht ob ich die kultur
komplett verstehen würde aber ich weiß
ich werde mir ihrem verstehen
[Musik]
das ist natur wie aus dem bilderbuch
der safari lodge außerhalb von
hauptstadt lusaka einsicht miriam und
chris the world
es ist nicht so richtig glauben
zum teil stand miriam und chris
insgesamt 70 glaube älterer foto miriam
und ihre geschwister sind schon vor sbb
gleis
[Musik]
und motto von chris
[Gelächter]
ältere foto miriam hand hochzieht
finanziert familie von chris kühn cityx
fest nicht leisten weil die schweiz
hochzeit macht dann hat es lag also für
mich ist das absolut nicht das problem
aber ich möchte dir wie soll ich jetzt
dann sage die grüne richtig wach und und
dann also quasi wird noch ausgeht dass
wirklich nett und als scherz parat um
einfache der schweizer und mir hat alles
im überfluss empfiehlt und dahin gar
nicht
ich glaube das ist wirklich bis wo ganz
schwierig ist zum überwinde auch
familienintern wir machen wir das genau
mit unterstützung von miriam und christa
system aber die unterstützung der
familie
neues beispiel jetzt zur hochzeit das
ist er ist sie dass sie überhaupt die
kleider haben die passenden kleider und
für uns ist das keine große sache für
sie ist dass er groß ist auch wo komm
ich jetzt die überwachung ich die rechte
spur über und zurück
also dann fangen wir mit thema das ist
daher gemacht hat
ich bin so nervös
ich kann es immer noch nicht glauben der
tag ist von diesem tag haben wir
geträumt
[Musik]
gott segne dich
und dann geht's los
der ströme traut züge mit dem bräutigam
chris
[Musik]
[Applaus]
janet brut miriam ihren großen auftritt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
miriam für die welt bist du nur
irgendjemand aber für jemanden bist du
die welt und dieser jemand bin ich
du bist mein ein und alles
miriam überraschte
christmas in ihrer muttersprache
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt darfst du die braut küssen
[Musik]
viereth wert bis die fit macht und
wie sehen sie ihre zukunft
[Musik]
mit babys haben wir es nicht eilig ich
möchte die zeit mit meiner frau genießen
vielleicht auch reisen
wir brauchen noch zeit wieder
wenn kinder da sind geht es vor allem um
sie
[Musik]
liebe kennt keine grenze und sie fragt
auch nicht noch ein pass
sie nimmt dieser der hand uns
überrascht ist immer wieder
[Musik]
[Applaus]
einigung
[Musik]
[Applaus]